your son is a remarkable young man he
has highly advanced cognitive skills he
has more in common with Einstein or
Mozart than he does with us I'd like to
work with your son help him develop the
skills he'll need to lead a full life
it's not gonna happen the world is not a
friendly place and that's where he needs
to learn to live my dad was an
accountant yeah you had the whole stick
Turkey pocket protector I have a pocket
protector there's a nice one you like
puzzles
tell me what you see was taken three
years ago by an undercover agent it's
the same person he was spotted in Tehran
Tel Aviv and Naples this guy risks his
life I'm cooking the books for some of
the scariest people on the planet drug
cartels arms brokers money launderers
assassins who survives this kind of
clientele imagine what secrets this guy
has
what are you doing here who are you
you're different sooner or later of
different scares people I have
difficulty socializing with other people
even though I want to there's people
looking for you
if their secrets get too big killing it
may be the cost of doing business
if you go down this river
you can't go back some of my clients are
quite dangerous why would your clients
follow you you're an accountant we have
the part of the police police can
protect you
so who is he do you count like a CPA you
come not quite
like a decision
your son as a remarkable young man it
wouldn't surprise me if he has more in
common